This one is actually a mold, so
it has, like, a texture that--
Oh, yeah.
My favorite is the
purple and the yellow.
OK.
[WARBLING]
We're using bacteria
as, basically,
an agent to paint with.
You can manipulate
the DNA of bacteria.
I want to use bacteria
as a detection
agent for toxins
in the environment
or for the detection of cancer.
In a scientific world,
the focus is actually
on the applications of this
material, idea, relationship.
As an artist, I'm
more interested
in the philosophical,
representational, or even
interpretational level.
Do they know what they're going?
[LAUGHTER]
[WARBLING]
The Visiting Artist
Program really
became active in the 1970s,
but even before that,
you really have to go
back to Gyorgy Kepes, who
came over from the Bauhaus.
He landed here and he said, oh,
I'm in a different environment.
This is an environment
full of scientists,
full of engineers,
full of people who are
trying to invent new things.
I really think the
artists and the scientists
have a lot to say
to one another.
He understood how the arts
could fit in at an institution
of MIT'S quality.
And by the late '60s, he
had created the Center
for Advanced Visual Studies.
The artists who were here were
not satisfied to just make art.
They wanted to develop
new technologies,
so it just came as a
kind of natural thing,
to create a visiting
artist program to enhance
this culture.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The kinds of artists we
wish to bring to our campus
are artists who have a
feel in the way they create
the art that intersects
with science and technology,
and to learn from us
as we learn from them.
If you could go
into fantasy land
and describe what would
be the ideal studio,
for any artist in
the 21st century,
it would be MIT facilities.
A lot of my work is trying to
figure out interesting ways
to combine materials
with computers,
and through the research, I
found out about Vik's work.
They sent Vik an email.
Immediately, he
responded, and he
was like, yes, I
want to come by,
I've heard about MIT and the
Media Lab for a long time.
This is a highly abstracted
image, because what's going on
is, that system there is
throwing charged particles
of gallium at the surface.
Vik has this vision of etching
castles into grains of sand.
And he asked, like,
can we do this at MIT?
Is there a way that we
can make an image that's
so small that we can
actually put it onto a grain?
We've been going through
all these different kinds
of equipment, creating really
cool techniques for etching it,
and then imaging it as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Science can benefit
enormously from interacting
with people who are
actually concerned about how
to represent the physical
world in a way that
is accessible but
also understandable.
4, 3, 2, 1, 0, and liftoff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Trevor Paglen came to
us with this project
where he wanted to put
a plaque on a satellite
in a geostationary orbit around
the Earth and, very likely,
outlive the planet.
How can we encode
information into materials
that can last for very,
very long periods of time?
These intersections between
deep time and human time
are very interesting
to think about.
He decided to put a photographic
archive of major events
in the life of the
Earthlings of this planet.
This is not something
I can do in my studio,
this is not something
I can do with materials
from my local art supply store.
This is the kind of
project that is really
only possible at a research
institution like MIT.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's really important about
the Visiting Artist Program
here is that it's
based on collaboration
with our existing
creative arts faculty.
Joan Jonas, our
performance artist
in the program in art,
culture, and technology,
was already collaborating with
the young jazz pianist Jason
Mraz, a MacArthur Award
winner, a brilliant pianist.
[PLAYING PAINO]
We brought Jason here
to MIT to work with Joan
to workshop a new
performance piece
by Joan called "Reanimation."
[PLAYING PAINO]
The tone and the
volume have to--
Don Byron is a
brilliant jazz composer.
You guys really sound amazing.
We brought him back to MIT,
where he worked on a new piece
for a gospel choir.
[MUSIC - "HOSANNA"]
(SINGING) We can't sing
without you, Hosanna, Hosanna.
And then, he composed
a concerto for clarinet
for Evan Ziporyn, which was
performed with the student wind
ensemble.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's just a musical
feast, quite literally.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They had quite a
rapport, the two of them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Students need to learn how
to play things in rhythm
and make them feel good.
So, I think I made the
thing rhythmically difficult
on purpose.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is [? Ravello ?]
[INAUDIBLE],,
and I thought that
this morning would
be, maybe,
interesting to explain
to you, my method of working.
Putting students in
contact with people
who are at the
top of their game,
whether it's in science, or
engineering, or the arts,
and having them learn by
creating alongside them
is a very special part of
MIT's educational philosophy.
There's no rules to this,
you just draw the impressions
that you have--
The McDermott Award is one
of the highest level artist
awards in the world.
In all cases, the
people who get the award
spend some time at MIT with
the students in some classes.
It's more than an
honor, it's also
an opportunity to benefit
from the creative culture
here on campus.
Any questions?
Any doubts, any fears?
When you're starting out,
you're an amateur at this,
you don't know what you're
doing is going to go off
in the right direction.
But then having someone
who's done it all their life
and is successful at it coming
to MIT, and working with you,
and making you feel
like you're part
of the process-- once you
feel that, you definitely
have a chance doing good work.
But don't be nervous.
[VOCALIZING]
You know?
Four, and.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The young conductor of the
Los Angeles Philharmonic,
Gustavo Dudamel, came
here to receive the Award.
Need an audience to--
Robert Lepage, the
Canadian theater maestro--
everything, he does it all.
With experience, we've
learned that we should not
force connections.
We let them, and eventually,
two or three things
seems to go together, and we
go, oh, there's a pattern there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've never really seen the,
quote unquote, "division"
between the arts and sciences
as any kind of dichotomy.
To be a complete
person, it makes sense
to be educated at both.
So having a vibrant arts
program at a school like MIT
is important for making
complete human beings,
for making human beings
that connect to the world.
Asking questions that
haven't been asked before.
When you put the
artist into the mix,
I think those questions
become larger,
they become more
speculative, and they also
have this human dimension.
This one is a mistake.
It's not an actual experiment,
but it still looks really cool.
Working with Vik
has really made me
think about the whole
cycle of technology and art
and how those two
are interwoven.
And it's just a beautiful
cycle, connecting nature
and the high technology
that we practice here.
It would be really interesting
to film, on a microscope, all
the details there.
There's a lot of
intricate stuff going on,
like, some bacteria
are swimming,
and other bacteria are just
climbing on top of each other
and they like to communicate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I.